we have staff in calais we have support
on the ground it is wrong to say that we
are just turning people back we are
absolutely not
this week home secretary pretty patel
told her french counterpart as well as
the house of commons that ukrainians
were not being turned away when they
tried to enter the uk
my colleague max jeffrey and i got in
the car and took the euro tunnel to
calais to find out exactly what was
going on
[Music]
it didn't take long after arriving in
calais to disprove pretty patel's
comments my colleague max and i wound up
at this hotel at around 1 30 in the
morning in calais city center the
streets were completely deserted but
there was a group of seven people
sitting on these couches
some sitting some sleeping they were
weary but there was nothing especially
noticeable about them except for the
ukrainian passports and documents that
were piled up in front of them we got to
speaking to them and had learned that
they had been trying to get to the uk
but had been turned back
we specifically spoke to muhammad and
his wife tanya who were looking after
their daughter who had also fled kiev
with them she couldn't have been more
than about 12 or 13 years old here's
their story you're trying to get the
train to london yes did you try today we
tried yes yesterday morning we tried the
embarrass station of
the train and the total duster you're
not allowed to enter the train because
uh
we have to get visa
visa yeah right to reach london do you
have family in london
uh yes i have is
yeah
yes and you try i have my family there
and uh they told me that uh joshua if
you want to arrive to london or things
will be all right
actually he's living in liverpool just
but yes yes you will meet me like in
london yes in the uk um so you've been
trying for several days now and you
can't get that more than
eight days ago like we would like to
sleep here but we don't have enough cash
to stay here our bank card doesn't work
most of
ukrainian bankers does work we have like
not that much of cash
we drive over to what is normally a fee
paying hostel but has been turned into a
safe haven for ukrainian refugees the
hostile is offering free accommodation
if and when rooms come up at the moment
it is completely full they offer three
hot meals a day they have games and
books for the children and crucially in
the back they're offering free visa
advice from the charity care for calais
here i meet a young ukrainian refugee
roxalona who's traveling with her
husband and her family and she tells me
her story yes yes we was
at this port in hidden valley but they
told us that there is like
no opportunity for us to have a visa
because we don't have a family so we had
to
go here again and stay here and just
they told us you have to wait and check
everyday uk's government site and just
website and watch if something will
happen if they will change something
despite claims that there are british
officials in calais giving advice and
helps ukrainian refugees we don't spot a
single one the person who seems to be
doing the heavy lifting is claire mosley
and her volunteers she's the founder of
care for calais if they have close
family in the uk they should get a visa
the issue is that the definition at the
moment is very
small so we're talking about parents um
brothers and sisters and sons and
daughters but of course most of us i
think would define our family a bit
wider than that
and when people are in when something
terrible happens you turn to your family
if you know if you can imagine an
emergency situation something as awful
as a war the first thing that you would
think of is your family and i do think
for most of us we would think of
something broader than just you know our
very very emerge immediate family
and of course in cali we meet people who
have lost their family in conflicts and
we it's really common we might meet a
child who's lost their parents so they
would immediately turn to their uncle or
their auntie it's the first person you
think of and this definition doesn't
include them
so that's one of the biggest issues
we're hitting right now people who might
have a cousin in the uk
um but they might have their their
brother or their father could be left
behind in the ukraine fighting
many refugees talk about their family
that have stayed behind in ukraine some
are there to fight but others
particularly older men have just decided
that they want to stay in their home
country come what may
there's a gentleman who showed me
photographs of his friends who were
killed
and he couldn't he didn't know enough
english to tell me what he was going
through so he was just showing me the
photographs to try and explain it um
there was a family who got to the border
in ukraine and the russian soldiers told
them to get out of their car and they
did and then one of the soldiers just
got in the car and drove off and it had
all their possessions everything they
own in the world in it so now they've
got no money they've got nothing
there is a lady who was pregnant here
and the stress of the last few days has
actually made her sick and she's in
hospital now
we leave the hostel and go to the local
train station califiel
here there are a lot of trains coming in
and out of other parts of france
including paris
here we're at the train station the city
center where many ukrainian refugees
have been entering calais and also where
some of them are leaving as the uk
government has refused to
open up a visa processing service here
it has been announced that there's going
to be one in lille which is 75 miles
away but many are being redirected back
to paris which is over 175
miles away visa appointments are being
scheduled for the next few days to over
a week
in advance and many ukrainian refugees
who we've spoken to are struggling to
figure out how they're going to come up
with the funds to stay here until their
visa appointment approaches we've been
watching people travel in and out of the
train station and despite the fact that
ukrainians have been given free passage
on transport throughout europe it
doesn't mean that there aren't still
bureaucratic hurdles to jump through and
it doesn't mean that there isn't
paperwork here we watched two men who
did have the right to board the train
back to paris argue with one of the
security people who was not familiar
with the paperwork that he was being
shown it went on for a good five or six
minutes finally his conductor colleague
stepped in and said that they indeed did
recognize the paperwork and the two
ukrainian men were allowed to board in
this scenario the security guard
actually did apologize and said to the
to ukrainian men that he was not
familiar with this paperwork um and that
he was truly sorry for holding up their
journey he let them board a silver
lining for them in what is no doubt
going to be a long journey to paris and
to the visa center
not every ukrainian that we met inside
the station was on their way to paris to
apply for a visa one young woman that we
met was on her way to paris to visit
some friends she's ukrainian but she's
been living in warsaw for two years and
she simply needed a break from all that
is going on in the region i sat down
with her in a cafe and she didn't speak
english i can't say spoke ukrainian we
communicated over translator
her story despite her not being the one
needing to get out of ukraine is
harrowing
she's traveling on her own but she tells
me she's in contact with her mother
i ask where is your mother now is she
still in ukraine
i come from a small town she can't get
out of it they don't let anyone out
they shoot at cars and kill so she stays
at home for now as soon as possible i
want to pick her up in poland
how have you found poland are you
welcome there
i really like it there i hope to pick up
my mum soon
across from the train station is the
local town hall where ukrainian refugees
have been coming to ask for advice but
they seem to be on this endless loop
officials will say you need to contact
the visa processing services they call
the visa processing services who say if
you don't have an appointment go to your
local town hall it's here where max
spots the refugees that we met in the
hotel lobby on that first night muhammad
tanya their daughter and the group that
they're with
i asked where they ended up that evening
and muhammad said that they had found a
stranger in the street they had told him
their story and he offered them their
couch for the night this is the very
very difficult and real reality
that many ukrainian refugees are
experiencing right now completely
dependent on a stranger's kindness and
also in a very vulnerable situation
and they haven't had any luck at the
town hall but we do tell them about this
hostel that we've been to we don't know
if there's space but it seems like it
could be a good bet
back at the hostel we speak to muhammad
and tanya again
my days was terrible like from last
night under the day like i did not sleep
well
i
i found like out there here
he is this guy he's from algeria held me
that sleeve for free
after i thought about my situation
yep
we wake up
and
we went to
to the office like which told us that we
have to go there
to ask how
they allowed us to enter england
but unfortunately they did not help like
just they told us go to
the
uk
embassy in paris
and we already went there like two days
ago
and they think that we're still waiting
i hope to gather things to be right and
now we are here thank god they gave us
free place for sleep for free here we're
we're at the youth hostel which is
currently hosting ukrainian refugees and
they are also offering free uh visa
advice which hopefully you can use
yes i will ask about it like it's going
to be my next step to ask about how i'm
going to get visa
yes i hope that's going to give me visa
even i was studying there in england yes
2014.
yes
you said to me about an hour ago that if
you could go home tomorrow you would
oh kiev if i go back to kiev like i
would go like without any question i
left my apartment
my life
my work
my car
all of things out of them there yeah but
if you have to settle on the uk as your
home
you're ready to do that why do you want
the uk to be here
uk because i've been there i told you
already like
i know like you care so good even i have
my family there they will help me out to
get a place there
yes uh
or even like for my uh daughter or my
wife
would be easily to them to stay there
because uh english language is more easy
than another language
i will thank like all the kids from
europe because they allowed us to enter
them countries appreciate that but
english for me is
like
near to my heart
england near to my heart and i hope in
one day it will allow us to enter
england
while we're at the hostel we see misha
maria and their children drive up misha
and his family made headlines across the
uk this week because maria and their
children ukrainian refugees were
struggling to get their paperwork filed
and their visa processed and felt stuck
in calais they get out of the car and
misha gives me a thumbs up they have
some good news here's what they tell us
you have some happy news
yes but we saw like we saw out of
paperwork and now we just know now we're
waiting to uh
get a date which is the date is the 15th
still but we're trying to get to um
earlier then appointments
[Music]
[Music]
so now we're just trying to uh get a
different way there
and it's different place it's not the
front that was going to go what sort of
parish was going to go to be going to
the brussels now
we're back in the uk we're just off of
the euro tunnel uh in the few days that
we've been in calais uk public policy
towards ukrainian refugees
has been updated uh the definition of
family member has been extended
so it's not just your immediate family
that the ukrainian refugee
can come see its extended family to so
that should in theory create a pathway
for more refugees to come and foreign
secretary lewis trust has announced a
pop-up visa center in liel
which is about 75 miles away from calais
there's been frustration about that
announcement uh because it is so far
away from calais and refugees will tell
you that they're starting to run out of
money they're not sure how much more
traveling they can do for start they're
not working right now
and some of them have been traveling
for weeks so their disposable income
that they brought with them is is
quickly diminishing
one young ukrainian woman pointed out
that
60 euro which will roughly buy you a
hotel room for a night in the center of
calais she said could buy her you know
everything that she would need for a
week back in kiev you know possibly two
if she was being careful so her money
would take her much further back at home
than it would in western europe so that
has to be accounted for as well um it's
very difficult to say to talk about the
numbers um in calais right now
especially because people are coming and
going with the visa situation now that's
becoming increasingly clear that the uk
is not going to create a visa process
that's easy to access in calais you have
people getting on the train in calais to
go back to paris in the same way that
you have people in paris who are coming
up to calais but no doubt
the day that we left the hostel that we
visited was still
chock full you know one in one out
policy but there are definitely
ukrainians showing up who are still
looking for rooms
one of the main messages from refugees
over the past few days is that they want
the uk government to do more they want a
pathway to come here especially if they
don't have family they feel like the uk
is completely cut off for them right now
but despite feeling disheartened about
that there was still so much spirit
among so many of the refugees a lot of
ambition a lot of people making plans
about the future even though they've
just left so much of their life in the
past so i guess the question for the uk
government now is do they want these
people with their ambition and their
drive to be in this country
you